army sergeant Bowe Bergdahl spent five
years as a prisoner of the Taliban and
starting today a military judge will
decide how long he will spend as a
prisoner in the u.s. Bergdahl pleaded
guilty last week to desertion and
misbehaving before the enemy the Idaho
native was captured back in 2009 after
he abandoned his post in Afghanistan
DeMarco Morgan is at Fort Bragg North
Carolina where the sentencing hearing is
about to begin
DeMarco good morning good morning Gail
you said it Bergdahl faces up to life in
prison for charges of desertion and
misbehavior before the enemy to the
soldiers who were wounded while
searching for Bergdahl are expected to
take the stand during the sentencing
phase
they don't just cut people's throats
they delight in cutting people's throats
Bergdahl in a rare interview said he
abandoned his fellow soldiers to draw
attention to problems within his own
unit after subsequent capture by the
Taliban
Bergdahl spent five years enduring
torture as a prisoner of war President
Obama brought him home in 2014 in
exchange for the release of five Taliban
prisoners from Guantanamo Bay Bergdahl
describes that release in an interview
as a brief moment of Liberty which later
became a flashpoint on the campaign
trail for then candidate Trump this
dirty rotten traitor he gets no gymtyme
the military judge in charge of
Bergdahl's case has already disposed of
a defense motion that President Trump's
comments denied Bergdahl the right to a
fair trial
last week the president stood by those
remarks I think people have heard my
comments in the past soldiers searching
for Bergdahl after his desertion were
wounded by enemy fire one soldier was
left paralyzed and unable to speak yes
we'll go back to kangaroo courts and
lynch mobs Bergdahl may still be able to
appeal sentencing based on president
Trump's past statement the people who
are to the point of saying yeah just
shoot him you can never convince those
people to change them
bergdahl says the Taliban who captured
him treated him better than the US Army
in an interview with the London Times he
said at least the Taliban were honest
enough to say I'm the guy who's going to
cut your throat here it could be the guy
I passed the corridor who's going to
sign the paper that sends me away for
life Nora
all right DiMarco thank you